the race to radicalism that's the focus
of tonight's angle all right for any of
you who had the misfortune of catching
even a few minutes of the Democrat
debate last night you'll undoubtedly
agree that it was a great night for
Donald Trump with the exception of
perhaps a candidate no one knows
tulsi gabbard what's clear is that the
Democrat Party has learned absolutely
nothing since 2016 they completely miss
read the results of last election and
have adopted essentially a
slash-and-burn strategy toward almost
every American tradition and
common-sense understanding of economics
and governance
now it's most entertaining I think if we
break down the current Democrat Lou
ninis into several moments first the
money grows on trees mentality my plan
would be to first of all make Community
College free we're supposed to be for
free College free public college for our
young people Universal childcare for
every baby age zero to five Universal
technical school to your college and
four-year college for everybody who
wants to give it a try if everyone in
this country health care is a basic
human right for free full-stop
healthcare it's not just a human right
it should be an American right and I
believe the best way to get there is
Medicare for all
I believe Medicare for all is the way to
do that now remember spend now figure
out a way to pay for it all later they
still think there's enough for rich
people to cover trillions and trillions
of dollars in new spending I'd like to
go back and see the grades of these
people though they got an economics 101
if they even took economics at all then
there is what I call the disconnected
from reality caucus at a time when 71%
of Americans are happy with the economy
Democrats have blinders on we know that
not everyone is sharing in this
prosperity I think of it this way who is
this economy
working for this economy has got to work
for everyone and right now we know that
it isn't I see every single day that
this economy is not working for average
Americans you get the repetition not
working for everyone the u.s. is about
to experience the longest economic
expansion on record and the unemployment
rate is at its lowest in nearly 50 years
across most demographics but sure the
economy isn't working yeah go with that
Democrats but don't worry because they
always have their favorite assortment of
cliches and bromides to choose from we
need to make sure everyone has a living
wage immigrants they do not diminish
America they are American diversity is a
strength equal pay for equal work in
this country ok whether they acknowledge
it publicly or not
look the Dems now know and everyone on
stage knew that most Americans think
President Trump has accomplished a heck
of a lot in his first two and a half
years from trade deals to the economy
from judges to criminal justice reform
so this means that they have to convince
you that they'll get more done three
things to know about me first I listen
to people and that's how I get things
done I'm one of the few candidates in
this race with executive experience with
a track record of getting things done I
think we need to get things done well at
least Delaney has in fact done something
in business otherwise its candidates
coming undone by the time the snooze are
wrapped up even the liberal commentators
on MSNBC had to admit that something was
wrong I'm a little disappointed I think
we needed to have more discussion on
those issues that actually affect
Americans every single day de Blasio is
mildly irritating I'm not sure there
certainly are some candidates running
for president that would be great Senate
candidates you've got to get rid of if
you're gonna do any of the stuff if
you're going to talk about any of these
issues in this
reasonable sounding way and I still in
my heart of hearts don't see anybody
that stage tonight that would be trauma
I can't believe I'm actually gonna say
this pinching myself but I agree with
Donny the Democrats lack substance
know-how pragmatism charisma credibility
and a connection to the American people
well then there was this fitting moment
that many online joked was kind of a
wink from on high
everybody's mics are on I think we have
a I heard that too that's okay
control room we've got we have yeah we
have the audience I apologize you guys
did get to hear this we are hearing our
colleagues audio
if the control we're gonna take a quick
break the most fun thing to do by the
way was to read the transcript and to
hear the underlined it happens it's
television can't dump on them for that
the Democrats though have been on a
perpetual break since 2016 and not a
commercial break a break from reality
and the American people will likely let
them stay in their alternate universe
where socialism works and you never run
out of other people's money Oh in a
ratings note this first Democrat debate
rated lower than both the Democratic and
Republican debates in the 2016 cycle huh
I wonder why and that's the angle